what's going on guys thank you so much
for clicking on this video we just
covered all the title announcements and
all that that came out and then they did
put out something on disney plus the
marvel studios 2021 disney plus day
special i heard that in the last couple
minutes there's some footage here now we
might have to like kind of tweak some of
this footage in order to get it visible
because i've been hearing a lot of
people have been dealing with block
issues at the moment unfortunately we're
gonna do our best if i take a couple of
uploads we're gonna get it to you guys
we'll do what we can and also wanted to
uh state obviously when we're reacting
to stuff we're reacting in real time so
we don't have all this like backed up
research going into it because it's all
brand new information but i heard that
that spider-man show is supposed to be
like tom holland's first year in the mcu
that's what a lot of comments were
actually saying so thank you guys for
informing us on that good to be up to
date and that does sound more appealing
than just another random high school
show so maybe tom holland will do the
voice anywho let's see what's going on
today
[Music]
[Music]
i can't tell the difference
between my waking life
and dreams
spectre
in your head
oh dude cool this looks so
gritty it devours you
nice
oh [ __ ]
she holds jennifer walters
i'm a normal lawyer
well not that normal these
transformations are triggered by anger
and fear don't make me angry
you wouldn't like me
what
it's not really the brown girls from
jersey city
you save the world
maybe now they do
i got this right totally
oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Music]
let's get to work
damn that was cool that was awesome yeah
that was awesome holy moly different
flavors i loved everything that we saw
there loved like everything that we saw
there yeah i mean the moon knight
footage is going to be the big takeaway
for for pretty much everybody we don't
know like a lot about moonlight all
right we're not gonna
we know basically everything we've
learned over the time of this being
announced that's how it all goes down
for us but you but all the shades that
we've heard it seems so prevalent here
in the trailer alone right down to like
that disassociative identity disorder
that he sort of struggles with you can
see things here that kind of remind me
of of uh james mcavoy from split yeah
but
much more super heroic in that nature
with a little bit of blend of like
batman slash daredevil yeah yeah yeah
yeah i mean
oscar isaac is just such a powerhouse
actor and like those voiceovers i'm just
gonna assume right now we're all
different shades of his personalities
and i cannot wait to see how he embodies
all those different things and rises to
the vigilante mantle you know i mean so
many of those shots look straight out of
a comic book a graphic novel yeah and i
loved that for disney plus which usually
strikes a bit more of a lighthearted
tone reminding me more of the grit that
we kind of got from the netflix days
from everything i've heard about moon
knight you gotta have that and of course
tortured he looks tortured he looks like
a true descent of a character yeah it's
like the guy who's gonna have to
struggle to accept who he is embrace
everything about himself while it looks
like a real struggle of what he has to
do like a tortured soul i love that you
got an actor like oscar isaac of that
caliber to pull this off this is just so
damn gritty and menacing i love it from
a few seconds i'm just like i want to
jump in right now exactly amen to that
and then the other uh stuff that we got
here like with jennifer walters i i that
behind this like shot from behind her
where she was in the hulk i was like is
that makeup
yeah yeah it looked practical i mean
maybe it's color correcting or something
but it certainly looked like you know
that was going to speak on display or
whoever's you know doing i don't know if
they're going to swap out actors for
when she's actually in hulk form but but
it puts it at an interesting time and
when it's taking place because spoilers
here shanghai i'm sure you've seen it by
now but you see bruce banner there yeah
and he's like really old and you're back
to his normal dude
yeah you see professor hulk so maybe
they'll explain that you see professor
hulk and then you get that thing that
kind of reminds me of like the whole tv
show yeah they would live right now and
then great seventies yeah yeah yeah so i
wanna see more of that tone and then of
course the miss marvel one which looks
the most family friendly and the
glimpses that we got there actually
reminded me of the movie shazam yeah
touchstone exactly yeah i mean which i
like a lot i like that movie a lot yeah
yeah it's a lighter and slightly more
endearing one in the dc world and yeah
this was it was the most endearing of
the three to me where it's like oh even
for like i think it's hard to sell a
tone and a vibe through a few images but
even then i was like i want to get to
know kamala khan she looks really
likable and really you know like an
interesting character well you're gonna
be you're gonna need to be able to have
that character though stand on her own
talk about jeffrey walters
back to there because i was kind of
hoping that with her they would lead the
she-hulk a little bit more with just her
and not having to have mark
because if i didn't know anything about
it i would assume that oh mark ruffalo
is a main is a main supporting character
and maybe he is i thought it was just
going to be like a a bit part or support
or like a translator
to kind of jump us in and then show up
every now and again yeah but it reminds
me of like whenever they do adaptations
of stuff for sequels or spin-off shows
there's like the limitless show
and then they let the marketing was
showing bradley cooper's in the first
episode which has you thinking bradley
cooper's going to be in it but not in it
but not at all no not at all so when you
do something like this i think that can
maybe might have audiences thinking that
oh mark ruffalo is going to be a main
character and maybe he is and maybe i'm
completely wrong about that but from
everything i've heard that's not
supposed to be the case it is
interesting because you know you don't
get much of a flavor from the other
shoes you get a lot of moon knight to
capitalize on but it looks very
confident in what they're doing yeah
absolutely i mean i did all three of
them really made me want to check them
out i appreciate that they all three
have a different feel to them you know
that's true i mean the jennifer walters
and and uh jeff walters she-hulk show
they didn't show us at all why she would
have to be she-hulk but i was like i
like the lawyer bit that they got yeah
but the moon knight thing it's gonna be
like a lot of that archaeological
exploration you see them with like the
egyptian artifacts and such which i know
is ingrained with uh the character
what's his name again mark spector mark
spector dammit yeah yeah with the mark
spectre character i'm just so excited
for oscar isaac man i feel like this is
the really the year maybe not this 2021
but the last 365 days people come out
talking about dune with him and how
freaking fantastic he is he's already
been beloved so much once you throw an
actor like him into here and then ethan
hawk's supposed to be in the show too
in this one series and then miss marvel
will probably be the hardest sell
because that's an exciting prospect due
to the fact that yes it's a brand new
character but also an unknown is in this
role and she idolizes a character nobody
seems to like them
i mean people like the character a lot
maybe not the live action marvel in the
mcu with real ourselves you get an
underdog by presence about right we
didn't see enough her powers on display
here right but it looks like a high
school show or something i mean that she
is she in junior high or high school i
forget actually you can see if you slow
down this footage you got like a caption
like a costume dress looks like a
costume party yeah they're all in like
superhero costumes oh it must be one of
those funny moments where like
everyone's dressed in costumes and she's
in her actual costume or she's dressed
as captain marvel and then her powers
ignite at some point like there's an
actual superhero amongst us i love
everything they've been showing us and
this all looks very great guys what did
you think which one of these three are
you most excited i would say moon knight
is usually i think it's in the exact
order they presented it
and miss marvel although i'm really
rooting for miss marvel because it is an
unknown so it's a harder sell whereas
like she-hulk has the benefit of having
mark ruffalo be there and miss marvel
doesn't have just it's just miss marvel
yeah yeah yeah yeah so it's a bit of a
harder sell but guys leave your thoughts
down below subscribe click that bell hit
that like button we will catch you guys
soon